[MUSIC PLAYING]
ALLAN LIVINGSTON: Good
afternoon, everyone.
Hi, how's it going?
Thank you for coming
to our session.
My name is Allan Livingston.
I'm a product manager
on the G Suite team.
And today, my
colleague, Chad, and I
are going to run you through the
benefits of going cloud native
and how that impacts TCO.
So now, TCO is a
relatively heavy subject.
So rather than diving right
in to looking at productivity
suites, I'm going
to try to think
about this in a more general
context and something
that we can probably
all relate to.
Something simple--
the light bulb.
OK?
So we all understand
the light bulb.
And so we're looking at a
nice, let's say, 100 watt
incandescent light bulb here.
And what is the TCO of one of
these using sort of standard US
power rates?
Anybody?
Any guesses?
What the total cost of
ownership of that light bulb
there would be including
the purchase price
and the electricity costs?
Any guesses at all?
AUDIENCE: $50.
ALLAN LIVINGSTON: Not bad.
$32.
$50 was the guess-- and $32.
In some markets that
would be correct.
So you got $32 there
from one of these guys.
And that's kind of a lot.
It's not great for
the environment,
but it's also a lot of money
when you think about it.
$32 for $1 or $2 light bulb.
So these came along, right?
Compact fluorescents.
And so the idea behind
these is very simple.
They're going to be a lot
more energy efficient,
maybe six times more energy
efficient than a similar light.
Any ideas what the
TCO on one of these
is going to be for the
equivalent lifespan?
They last longer, so you've
got to kind of prorate it down.
Any ideas?
Rough costs including
the purchase price?
About $10 is about right.
And so it depends on what
you get it for but about $10.
And so significant
savings, right?
And the payback period
on them is pretty quick.
It's about six months.
Depending on, again, you
know, the sort of a typical
set up that you're going to see.
So this is a project
that you would-- you
know, if you're thinking
about investing in a project
and you're thinking
rationally, it's
probably a pretty
good investment
to make-- these light bulbs.
But then you're
going to say, well,
there's the time
value of the money.
It's the payoff.
And again, I used
some variables here,
but unless you're financing
it at 87% or higher rate,
then it makes sense to get it.
It actually makes
sense to just buy them
on your credit card and
then not even pay the bill.
That's what a good
investment they are.
But there's one thing
that's kind of weird.
And you see this-- is these
things never really caught on.
And they've been around for--
well, I've got 25 years
here, but they've actually
been around longer in
other form factors.
And you see them in
2000 kind of coming up,
and you've actually seen them
kind of back down a little bit
here.
This is US adoption data.
It's actually blended, I think,
Connecticut and California.
But you see them coming
down, and then you
see these kind of weird
bumps along the way.
And what was happening
the whole time
is there were a lot
of government programs
and incentives to
just incentivize
people to get these things.
And even though the TCO
on them and the payback
was already
ridiculously high, you
know there were all these
incentives where you get
them cheap or things like that.
But then the retailers would
find people would come back,
they'd get one cheap.
And then they'd go--
you know, they wouldn't
like it, or they'd come back
and the program wasn't
there, so they'd recommend
putting incandescent back in.
And there was another
problem with them,
which was they're actually
a deficient product.
Right?
And they're deficient for
a whole bunch of reasons.
Most people find the light
quality in them not very great.
They flicker a bit.
The form factor, they
tend to stick out.
They're getting better
now, but they actually
tend to stick out.
A lot of the older
ones had slow start up,
and they're not compatible
with dimmer switches
and some other applications.
So you look at that, you've got
a product with compelling TCO
arguments.
Really far and away a slam
dunk as far as investment
and yet it struggles
to catch on.
So TCO by itself
isn't enough, which
brings us to this guy here.
LED light bulb.
So I ran the same
kind of numbers
on these, same power rates.
TCO is a bit better on this--
about $7.
They're a little more
efficient, and they last longer.
So you can amortize
the cost over longer,
and so it brings the TCO down.
They were already compelling--
compact fluorescents
were already compelling.
This is a little bit better.
And you're financing, again,
as long as your credit card--
which I hope it isn't-- is
charging you less than 112%
a month, you're good to just
charge it on your credit card
and not even pay the bill back.
It's such a good investment.
So solid, solid investment.
So it's got the same kind of
financial characteristics,
but it's actually
seeing better adoption.
So this is the
same data overlaid,
where you've got the blue
is the compact fluorescent,
and then the red is
the LED light bulbs.
And you're seeing a very sharp
uptick in the LED adoption
and a corresponding decrease
in the compact fluorescent.
And it's not explained by that
relatively modest difference
in TCO.
It's clearly explained by
the product characteristics
themselves.
It's better light quality.
Form factor is great.
You can identically
match incandescent.
You can also have other form
factors, startup's good.
And they're compatible
with dimmer applications.
The dimmer switch is
another application.
So it's just a superior
product, right?
It does exactly what the
incandescent light bulb does,
but it's got a better TCO.
It's not an inferior product.
It also does other things.
Because they're so small,
you've got new formats.
And the extreme
long life of them
allows you to permanently
put them into some fixtures,
and you don't even have to
have them to be removable.
So it looks like a product with
a really strong runway because
of this.
So let's talk about another one.
Well, let's kind
of lay this out.
And so we've got our TCO
getting better as you go up
and the product benefits
getting better as you right.
Nice, simple two by two.
Really, what it
looks like is you
need both in this
world to be successful.
You need to have both a
compelling product that's
really usable and really
good for the purpose and TCO.
Because people aren't
just number crunchers.
They need something
that makes sense.
Let's talk about
another common case.
We've got ourselves
a hybrid car.
And so what do hybrid cars do?
Well, typically
they've got a bit
of a premium over the
conventional cars,
and they've got a bit of
a better fuel economy.
But with the way gas
prices are right now,
it's actually not really
a compelling TCO buy.
And so this is a
study that was done
on 2016 models, a projection
with current gas prices.
And it found that only
24% of hybrid cars
had a projected TCO lower than
the equivalent conventionally
fueled cars, because
the premium was just
too high for the savings.
And all things being equal,
some people prefer hybrids,
some people don't like
the way they drive
and things like that.
Let's even just call them equal.
That itself is not a great
trend for hybrid cars.
And you see that in the relative
penetration of US auto sales.
And so they actually
are coming down
as the fuel prices come down.
So even the price is probably
equal, or some people
for one way or the other.
But without the TCO
element there, it
doesn't make a
whole bunch of sense
to ask people to put that
investment in ahead of time
and then not even
see the payback.
There's certainly
environmental benefits
which appeals to a
niche of the population,
but the straight dollars and
cents just don't bear it out.
And so it would seemed
like if hybrid cars stayed,
don't get their
characteristics fixed up,
that they don't
have a great set up.
So with that out of the way--
just kind of some framing.
Let's apply this to a lot
more complicated subject which
you guys actually came here.
Because I'm guessing
you probably
didn't come down to the
basement of the Marriott
on a lovely afternoon to
talk about light bulbs.
So we're going to talk
about Sass applications
and productivity software.
And so just like
light bulbs, we've
got to consider more
than just the cost
when we're looking at this.
You've also got to look at
the product benefits, the fit,
and also what kind
of new possibilities
it opens up, the product, just
like we saw with the LED light
bulbs.
And so when we're thinking
about the G Suite,
we're thinking about
three primary areas here.
There's the productivity
enhancements.
There's cost reductions.
And then there's
replacement savings
that you're going to get.
And so with that I'm going
to ask my colleague Chad
to come up and run us
in a little more detail
through the way that we
see the G Suite delivering
productivity benefits that
really help the bottom line.
CHAD TYLER: OK.
Thanks, Allan.
We wanted to start off by
talking about productivity
because these
benefits aren't always
as obvious at first
glance, but they're
a key part of the value
that G Suite offers.
We want to think
about things like what
is possible in G Suite
and the cloud that
wasn't possible in an on-premise
or even hybrid environment.
How can we take
collaboration and make it
a really powerful tool
that can make people more
efficient and more effective?
And how can we
engage and connect
with even a remote
and deskless workers
so that we can bring them
in and make them more--
closer part of the team.
And so these are
some of the things
we want to think about as we go
through this next section here.
The first thing that
I want to touch on
is real time collaboration.
Forrester recently
did a study that
showed that when
multiple editors can work
on the same document, slide,
or sheet at the same time,
it actually reduces the
amount of time it takes
to create that content by 20%.
This translates into
about 15 minutes
to two hours per
employee, per week,
depending on the
type of role they're
in or how collaborative
that employee tends to be.
But beyond just
the time savings,
they also found that this type
of collaboration makes people--
makes meetings more
effective as well.
Because since people have been
working on the same document
together, they've seen how
the content has evolved,
and how they've gotten
to where they are.
They understand
the history of it.
And they're also all looking
at the same version of it.
So when they get
to a meeting, they
spend a lot less time working
to try to get on the same page
and trying to make
sure everybody's
looking at the same thing,
and they can dive right
into the core part
of that meeting
and the core purpose
of the meeting.
So both of those
have a huge impact
on how effective
employees can be.
I also want to hit
on Hangouts as well.
Because what Hangouts does
is it creates an environment
where it's very easy to
engage with other teammates
over video.
Where you can have
those face-to-face
chats really quickly
instead of having
to rely on slower
forms of communication,
like email, where
there tends to be
some latency and some
lag between asking
questions and getting answers.
So Hangouts is also a
key part of the real time
collaboration within G Suite.
Mobility is also something
I want to touch on.
In today's world with the
prevalence of mobile devices,
it's more important than ever
that employees and people
within an organization
can access
the information they need from
any device and from anywhere.
And G Suite enables this.
Whether you're on Android,
or iOS, or a laptop,
using Google Drive your
files are there at any time,
and they're easy to access,
they're easy to work with.
So mobility is something
else that's really key.
Beyond just being able to
access the information though,
G Suite also enables people to
use their own personal devices.
So instead of having to
adapt to a new device
and the differences between
that and what they normally use,
they can use something
that's comfortable to them
and be more focused on what
they're trying to do and less
on how they're trying to do it.
I want to hit on
Hangouts again here,
specifically how management
communicates with their teams.
Forrester also found that
when management effectively
uses Hangouts, they can reduce
the amount of travel time
they have to do by 40%.
So beyond just having
a reduction in the time
they have to spend traveling
and the budget that goes along
with that, that let's
management focus
a lot more on their
important tasks
than jumping on an airplane
to try to fly somewhere
to communicate with their team.
This is just a quote by Keith
Chisholm, who at the time
was a program director
at Rentokil Initial.
And they actually saw this
benefit within their company.
They saw that when they
started using Hangouts
in the leadership
team, they were
able to communicate
with their team
and really connect
with them and have
a really good
understanding of what
was going on with their team.
And at the same time they were
able to reduce their travel
by 40%.
This, again, beyond just
the big budget decrease
that that had on
their company, it also
increased the communication
and the impact
that leadership could
have while still
giving them more time
to focus on other tasks
that they needed to get to.
Now, when I talk about
social engagement,
your first thought might
not be productivity.
But what social, and in the case
of G Suite, what Google+ does,
is it enables people
to form connections.
Beyond the formality
of a meeting
or the brevity of a
hallway conversation,
it lets people
share ideas, and it
lets them share their interests
with each other, regardless
of their location,
regardless of their role.
So as they start to form
these more social connections
with the people that
are around them,
they become more
and more engaged
in what they're working on
and who they are working with.
PwC did a study that showed
when employees are engaged,
they actually are 30% more
satisfied with their jobs,
and they generate
32% more ideas.
So what social
engagement does is
it makes people more
invested in their workplace.
It makes people more excited
about what they're working on.
It increases the
retention of people
staying within their
workplace and staying
within their
organization and helps
them to have a bigger impact
because they're more invested
in what they're working on.
They're more invested in the
goals of that organization
and what they're
trying to accomplish.
So social within an
enterprise can have
a huge impact, a
profound change in how
employees feel about where they
are and what they're doing.
And then the last thing I want
to touch on in this section
is extensibility.
Through the APIs
that are offered
through G Suite and a
tool called App Maker,
organizations can
integrate their systems
and infrastructure to
be part of the suite.
So basically that means
that all of your information
and all of your data
can work together
to create solutions that weren't
possible before when everything
was segmented and segregated.
I want to touch a little
bit more on App Maker, too.
Because what App
Maker is is it's
a tool that enables
organizations
to very easily create
powerful tools that
can automate processes that
employees and people would
normally do over and over again.
So App Maker takes
those redundant tasks
that people are working
on and automates them
so that they can focus on
things that have more impact
and are more central to the
goals of the organization.
App Maker's something that
we're really excited about.
And I encourage everyone--
during the product
roadmap session on Friday,
they're going to be doing some
demonstrations of App Maker,
and how you can use it, and how
you can build tools with it.
I'd encourage everyone, if you
have a chance to attend that,
because it's something
that we believe can really
change how people work.
Now, I've talked about a
lot of classic examples
of productivity.
I've talked about how we can
take what people are doing
and make them more
efficient at it,
how we can kind of change
how they approach problems.
What I want to do now is
talk about how we're kind
of going beyond productivity.
How we're you using
Google Smarts and Machine
Learning to start to
remove some of the tasks
that people normally
would have to focus on.
And honestly, this,
in my opinion,
is where things get
really exciting.
Because we are just
barely starting to
scratch the surface
in this area.
We're barely starting to
look and see what's possible.
But as you'll see, even
these early examples
can really change
how people work
and can make them more
productive and more efficient.
So we're excited about
what we can do here
and what we can
bring to the market.
But again, these
are just the start.
So the first thing
I want to touch on
is what's called Sheets Explore.
What Sheets Explore
does is it enables
people to use real world
language to build a query.
So instead of having
to go into a sheet
and figure out what
formulas they want to use,
and how they put those formulas
together to answer a question,
they can simply
type the question
that they have, and sheets will
build the formula for them.
Now, this is hugely important.
Because what we have found
is that only about 30%
of the people in an organization
know how to effectively build
a formula and how to answer
a question based on data
that they have.
So if you think about
that, that means
that 70% of the people
in your organization
are answering questions
and are making decisions
with less information than
they could and should have.
That's huge.
So Sheets Explore
opens up all the data
that an organization
has to better
inform and to better answer
questions that people have.
We think this will have
a profound impact when
widely used on how
people look at data.
And you think about how
much data we have nowadays,
and how that's just going
to be more and more as we
move forward.
We're really excited
about the impact
that Sheets Explore can have.
The next one is
called Slides Explore,
or sometimes called Auto Layout.
And what this does is it allows
people to put images or text
on a slide, and then
use this feature to help
them organize the slide and
help them figure out the what
the layout should look like
and build a deck around it.
What we've seen in measuring
this is that when people use
Slides Explore, they create
their decks 60% faster than
those that don't.
So that's a lot of time.
When you think about
building a deck
and how much time
you spent on it--
Slides Explore helped me
with this deck, by the way.
But you think about how much
time you spend building a deck,
and think about saving
60% of that time.
Instead of focusing on how
you're going to tell the story,
focus on the story you're
telling and the content you're
putting in and
making sure that you
have the information that you
need to get your point across.
It, therefore, goes into
making meetings more effective.
It goes into making
sure that you're
telling the story you
should be telling,
and lets you invest that
time into something that's
more meaningful to
make sure that you're
helping other people to
understand your point.
Another kind of seemingly
simple example--
within Calendar there's
features that we're
doing, such as conflict
assistance, automated room
booking and scheduling, finding
details about rooms so you
can understand what
different functionality
that room might have.
Very simple things but things
that used to be kind of a pain
point to figure out where you
needed to have your meeting,
and whether there
were conflicts,
and who needed to be there, and
what time they could be there.
And so we're taking some
of those pain points
and removing them and
making it much easier
to schedule a meeting.
And what we've measured is
that these small improvements
save about three minutes
every time someone schedules
a meeting.
So you think about
how many meetings
you schedule throughout the
week or throughout the month,
and you take three minutes
for each time you did that,
and you put it
back in your pocket
to spend on something
more important.
Something that has a
greater impact, something
that helps you improve.
So this, again, a
seemingly simple example
that just goes to take more of
the pain out of doing your job
and making sure you can
focus on having an impact.
This example is
called Smart Reply.
What Smart Reply does is
it generates simple replies
to emails based on the
content of the email.
So a simple thing--
but what we've seen is that
within inbox on mobile,
10% of all replies
are done using
smart reply, which translates
into 15 minutes, per person,
per day.
Again, something where we're
taking time out of what you
would normally be typing
on your mobile phone
to try to respond to an email
and making it much more simple.
Beyond just the time
savings, though, it also
enables people to
respond more quickly.
So when you read an email--
I can't think of how many
times I've read an email
and said I don't have
time to respond right now
and that I'll come
back to it later.
You think if you could
just respond very quickly
you'd unblock the people that
are waiting for the information
that they need to
continue forward.
So beyond just the 15
minutes per person, per day,
we're talking about unblocking
entire groups of people
so they have the
information in context they
need to move forward.
And then this last
example that I
want to talk about
in this section
is actually a really big one.
It's called Cloud Search.
And MacKenzie did
a study that showed
that knowledge workers
spend about 20%
of their time looking
for information.
20% of their time--
that's the equivalent of
one out of every five people
not showing up to
work in a given day.
You think about the
impact that that
has of people just
searching for things
and not being able to find them.
So Google-- we made our name
by organizing information
and making it easy to find.
We started by doing
that for the internet,
and Cloud Search is
us starting to do
that for your organization.
We're taking all the
information that you
have in different systems,
in different areas,
and we're organizing it, and
we're making it easy for people
to find.
But beyond just search,
what we're also doing
is suggestions
and notifications.
So imagine that you're
preparing for a meeting,
and you can automatically
be suggested
meeting notes from
the previous time you
met with the same group.
You can be suggested
content that
was attached to an
email or the meeting
invite before the
meeting was held.
You can be suggested
different content about things
that you're working on that
are relevant to the topic
of the meeting.
So instead of having to go
and look for that information
and to try to prepare
for your meeting,
it can automatically be there,
waiting for you and ready.
Which means you go, again, to
this meeting more prepared.
The meeting is more
productive because everybody
had the information
they need beforehand.
And you make sure
that you accomplish
the goal of why you're there.
Another important part about the
suggestions and notifications
is that a lot of
times people just
don't think to search
for information.
They don't think about--
they don't know what they
don't know, you could say.
So they might not be
thinking that they
need to go look for
information about this topic,
but we could
automatically suggest
that it might be relevant based
on who you're meeting with
or why you're going
to this meeting.
So we're unlocking
more information,
we're making it easy
to find, and we're
making sure that you think
about it and it's there for you.
So I've thrown a ton
of numbers at you.
Almost every slide
had a number on it.
So I just wanted to put
it all there for you
so you could look at it.
It's a great picture slide.
I see a lot of people
taking advantage of that.
But I don't want to go through
this line by line right now,
I just want to touch
on a few of these.
We talked about how we're taking
20% of a knowledge worker's
time, and we're reducing
that to a fraction.
So instead of searching
for 8 hours a week
for the information they need,
they can simply search for it
and find it, or it can be
suggested to them without them
even thinking about it.
We're taking 70% of
the organization that
doesn't have access to the
data analysis they need,
and we're making it
available for them.
We're informing them and helping
them to make better decisions.
We're saving 15 minutes
per person, per day,
sending email,
making it very simple
for them to send that off.
And by enabling people to
work together on documents,
we're saving 20% of their time
in creating those and helping
them to be more prepared
and more in sync when
they go to that meeting.
So productivity
really is something
that you should think about as
you think about total costs.
All of these things are
things that you're currently
spending money on in
your organization,
and it could be more effective.
That could be more productive.
You could have that time back.
And so we'd
encourage you, as you
think about total costs--
and a lot of times
when you think about cost,
you think about solid numbers
that you're saving on
servers and infrastructure,
but we'd encourage you to
also think about productivity.
Because as Allan
talked about, it's
not just about the ROI over
time of the light bulb.
The CFL light bulb
did not take off
because it wasn't
convenient, it didn't
help improve the product.
And so productivity
here is what we
want you to think about first.
And then I'm going
to pass it to Allan
so he can talk a little
bit more about the costs
and replacements that we're
offering through G Suite.
ALLAN LIVINGSTON: Thanks, Chad.
Yeah, and as Chad
said, we wanted
to start with productivity.
Because these numbers
here have the potential
to be really transformative to
the way that companies operate.
And you see that when
you see traditionally
run companies to fully
cloud native companies,
the real difference
in productivity.
And it helps to explain
a lot of situations
where people are working a lot
and not getting things done.
It's because they're
spending their time
doing these things that
are not productive.
And the change, and
the move to the cloud,
and the increasing prevalence
of useful machine learning,
has the potential to
transform the way people work.
So we think it's really the most
exciting and most compelling
element on it.
Now I'm going to switch and
talk about more traditional TCO
elements, which is cost
reductions and savings.
Because they're
substantial as well
and have historically
been the primary element
that people looked
at for the cloud.
So we talked about--
and here's a good quote
we've got from a customer.
And so you've got 15%
increase in productivity
and at 70% cheaper.
OK?
And where does that come from?
Well, IT savings
is a great element.
The average on-premise system
has very low utilization.
It's really not safe
to run your servers
at a very high utilization.
You've got to keep a
lot of spare capacity,
because you're going to
have really spiky demand.
Everyone's coming
online at the same time,
everyone's in at 9:00, no
one's there on Sundays.
These type of things, right?
Or you're going to
have other ones--
you've got to have that
slack in the system.
So it's really
expensive to maintain.
It means that if
you're aggressive,
82% of your capacity is IO
most of the time, maybe 88%.
But it's an awful lot.
And it's not just the cost of
the hardware-- it's the power,
it's the space, the
maintenance as well.
And the cloud architecture's
superior in that regard,
because we amortized
it globally.
And that takes a
spikiness out of it.
And it really allows you to
more adequately and provision
more correctly.
So that you can provision the
amount of capacity you need,
not the amount of
capacity you might
need at one point in time.
It also allows IT Com
staff to focus more
on the core business.
If you think about it,
running data centers
is not the core business
of most companies.
But if you're on-premise, that
needs to be a core capability.
You've got to be good at
running data center scalably.
And that focus takes
away, necessarily,
from the focus on
the core business.
We've heard some
examples of that
this morning in the
Keynote, where companies
were able to shed that.
I like the Disney quote--
they want to tell stories.
They don't want to run
a bunch of servers,
and they can focus
on that piece.
And that freeing the IT staff
to focus on actual business
problems is really valuable.
Here's another example we
saw from City of Monterey--
30% IT cost savings just
from these kind of elements
that I talked about.
Security is another big one.
Google's got over 700 world
class security engineers.
You can take those 700, and
they're working together
to secure everything.
But when you're on-premise,
you don't have 700 engineers.
And it's sort of like what Eric
Schmidt talked about today.
Is just not a good idea.
Don't try to build that.
Don't try to go hire
700 world class security
engineers to work full time on
securing your on-premise data.
But what it allows--
by going to the cloud
companies can save all of that.
They can also secure their data
more and be more effective.
The idea is to remove
the physical boundaries
that you have in your company.
So traditionally, companies
were kind of locked in.
If you're an on-premise,
you can access the data.
That's not really
acceptable for nowadays,
and so you've got
to get rid of that.
But if you do that, then
you've got to secure everything
because you've got
all these threat
vectors can be coming in.
So you can go and hire
700 security engineers,
or you can deal with
occasional breaches.
And data breaches are extremely
expensive to companies.
For a global company,
the average data breach
costs between $3.5
and $3.8 million.
But obviously, many data
breaches that we see
are actually more than that.
They're an existential threat
to the company themselves--
losing all of your
customer data,
things like that, lack of
trust, the loss of trust.
So this is a really
key element here.
There's sort of the
superficial savings
you see, and then the other
side, the downside risk
that you've got if you don't
have adequate security.
And agility is great.
And so this is sort of the other
side of the utilization piece
that I talked about.
In an on-premise world,
you need to provision
for your expected peak demand.
So whatever peaky time you've
got from your workforce,
you need to provision that
plus a little bit of a buffer.
But you don't really
have any agility there.
And the example
this morning of--
I guess we lost our slides,
but I'll keep talking.
So the example this
morning of Pokemon Go
was a really good example.
So the creators of that
experienced load that far, far
exceeded what they expected.
Immediately they exceeded
their lifetime projection.
I can't even remember the
multiplier that it was.
But if you think
about that, they
wouldn't have been
able to deal with that
in an on-premise model.
So that agility allows you
to explore new businesses,
and it allows you to also
focus on expanding quickly
into new markets.
And at this point, I'm actually
running out of content.
So I'm hoping that we
can get the slides back.
You have those cues where
you think of the next thing
that you're going to do.
I shall bravely soldier on here.
Actually, I was going to talk
about the release process
as well, because that came up
this morning on the agility
side.
And it was same thing,
the creator of Pokemon Go.
If you think about
how that works,
they were able to not
focus on building out
this IT infrastructure-- as was
Snap, as well, for Snapchat.
And what that
allowed them to do is
it allowed them to have
a much faster development
process because they were freed
from all of that other load.
So that agility brings
you these benefits
of being able to release
software and develop
faster and solve customer
problems a lot faster.
And I think we're almost there.
We're almost there?
Good.
And another one that
I wanted to talk about
was change management.
Change management is
a cost, obviously.
Anytime your employees are
going through a change,
you've got to
manage that change.
You don't have to
manage that change,
you can let the employees
deal with it themselves,
but oftentimes that
is not advisable.
And so one of the
concerns people
have sometimes
when they're moving
the cloud is they think
about change management.
How expensive
that's going to be,
that it's going to
be a big undertaking.
And I think you heard
some examples this morning
at the Keynote.
Where you've got some customers
coming in and activating
20,000 employees over the
weekend or things like that.
And what we've found
with customers moving
to the cloud is because the
experiences are kind of what
they're used to and
what they expect,
the change management process is
really, really easy and simple.
And in fact, the
average payback--
when we looked at
that Forrester study
that Chad talked about--
the average payback
for a change management
program was less than a month.
So even more ridiculous
than the payback
that we talked about
for the LED light bulbs.
That effectively
it's instant payback.
There's very lightweight
change management process,
you roll people out
over the weekend,
you go, and then it's
really effective.
And so that's something
that we think is-- very much
plays into.
Here we go.
Perfect.
Thank you.
We're back on track.
Almost-- excuse me.
Could we-- this one, not quite.
OK.
So let's go on and let's talk
about replacement savings.
The other element, and
this is the real advantage
of moving to a suite
versus point solutions,
is replacement savings.
And over the past
couple of years,
we've been really
extending the G Suite
to provide more capabilities,
more capabilities
that businesses need.
The math on this is
getting easier and easier
as we go through.
So G Suite consists
of a whole series
of different applications
that work seamlessly together,
and we've introduced
new ones very recently.
Chad talked about G+,
talked about Cloud Search.
Those are both recent
additions to the G Suite.
We've also got Keep is in here.
And we also have a lot
of admin capabilities
that we don't show as logos
here but are super useful.
So let's talk about
data loss prevention.
Data loss prevention allows
you to set customized policies,
so that depending on the content
that you're seeing in documents
or e-mails, you're controlling
the sharing settings,
or who can send what
to where, or how
you trigger a report on that.
And the cost of data
loss prevention software
varies, but sort of a
typical market example
would be around $2
a month per user.
And that's just
included in the G Suite.
No.
We're not-- the
clicker, no, we're not.
So we're getting there.
It doesn't click through.
OK.
So the next one-- let's
talk about e-discovery.
So in order to
comply-- companies
have to comply with legal
requests and data discovery
elements, and so they need an
e-discovery in our cloud native
system.
And the G Suite includes
that with Vault.
And we looked at
the market, and we
found that systems like
that can cause-- the cost
is variable again,
but a lot of times
a market reference price would
be about $60 a year per user.
Which again is pretty material.
Let's see if we can do that.
OK.
Here we go.
Perfect.
And so there's e-discovery.
Let's keep going on that.
Another one's
identity as a service.
And so there's
this transformation
that's happening in the cloud,
in IT infrastructure right now.
Obviously, everyone's moving
from an on-premise way of doing
your directory into the cloud.
And you can either buy a
point solution for that,
or you can have one
integrated with the G Suite.
And the price of this is
actually quite variable.
You're going to
see prices anywhere
from $12 a year per user,
up to $72 a year per user,
depending on the functionality.
And we're continuing
to build out
these capabilities in G Suite.
So the advantages are--
you go with the G
Suite, you can get
rid of all of these
category items.
You just cross them right out.
One more-- mobility management.
How are you securing
your devices?
I said we're in
multi-device world,
you need to secure those.
You need to set policies
on your devices.
You need to control what
kind of applications
are installed on your
devices by your users.
You need to occasionally remote
wipe them if they're lost.
All that is provided by
Enterprise Mobility Management.
Some people would traditionally
have called this Mobile Device
Management.
Average market price
you're seeing is around $54
a user per year.
So all that adds
up to an awful lot.
We talked about the
productivity savings.
IT cost savings.
And we also talked about the
replacement cost savings.
So Chad's going to run you
through the total cost,
TCO calculator, in a
little bit more detail
and how that all fits together.
Thank you.
CHAD TYLER: Thank you, Allan.
Sorry.
OK.
There we go.
Thanks, Allan.
So we've talked
about a lot of costs
and a lot of things
that feed into costs.
However, total
cost of ownership,
it varies largely
between companies
based on where
you're coming from,
or what you're trying to do,
and where you want to end up.
So it's hard sometimes
to understand
exactly what TCO will look like
in your specific organization.
And that's why we built a total
cost of ownership calculator.
What this allows
you to do is enter
in your company
information, details
about where you operate,
what you're trying to do,
how many people you have
within your organization.
It lets you enter in what
you're using right now as
far as software hardware
and productivity,
so that you can enter
in things that are
very specific to your company.
And then what it
does is it generates
a picture of what you
might be able to expect
switching to G Suite.
So it breaks things
down based on where
you might see savings, what
your return on investment
might be, and kind of gives
you a better picture, very
specific to you, what
you might expect.
And so it's a little bit
more applicable directly
to what you're coming from
and what you're looking at.
So this is available
for you to use.
The easiest way to find it is
probably just to go to Google
and search for G
Suite TCO Calculator.
The first two
results that come up
will be two different
versions of a calculator
that you can use.
As you can see by the
purple, I've clicked on both.
But the first version, it
relates to the Forrester study
that we've referenced
several times
throughout this presentation,
based on some of the results
they've found, and
more to productivity
and different
elements like that.
And the second one is
more general purpose,
where you can see what you might
expect coming from on-premise,
or hybrid, or a
different cloud provider,
and just kind of gives you
a better picture of the cost
that you could
save and the impact
that G Suite could have on
your total cost of ownership.
So we'd encourage you to
go and check those out just
to get a better picture
of some of the things
we've talked about today
more directly applicable
to your specific company.
So I want to pass
it back to Allan
so he can summarize some of
the things we've talked about.
ALLAN LIVINGSTON: Great.
Thanks, Chad.
And so just to recap
where we're at.
We have these three areas that
we wanted to focus on TCO--
productivity, cost reduction,
replacement savings.
And we created a convenient
cheat sheet here at the end,
so let's run through these.
And the productivity
benefits we talked about
and Chad had talked
about in detail--
and in my mind, these feel like
the most compelling elements
of any cost strategy.
You're talking about
helping employees--
and these all add up.
So reducing the amount of this
20% that information workers
spend finding the correct
information, or in some cases,
not finding it, because that
can be even more expensive.
Helping people spend
less time sending email.
And Chad only talked
about one element of that,
we're doing a whole bunch more
on inbox to even bring that
down further.
Helping you spend less
time scheduling a meeting.
Average information
worker spends up
to 300 minutes a month
scheduling meetings.
So bringing that down and
all the frustration that that
brings with it.
And the suboptimal
scheduling-- right?
The computers are much better
at these kind of scheduling
problems than humans.
And so the productivity
gains are there.
Being able to complete
slides fundamentally faster.
And this one is
really interesting.
Because I remember when
I first saw this feature,
I was a little skeptical of it.
What kind of did it for
me was-- so I was at home,
and I have two elementary
school children, and one of them
was doing a report.
And he was sitting there
getting the slides lined up
and getting all the
images lined up.
And the other one walked
by and looked at him
and said, just use Slides
Explore already, and rolled
his eyes and walked away.
And it told me two things--
one, I've got to do a better
job in parenting overall.
Kind of got to watch
that attitude a bit.
But then the other
point was just
how easy this stuff was
to use even for kids.
And that it was so obvious
to them the value of it.
And so that's a
huge element there.
40% reduction in travel costs--
I, myself, actually travel
quite a lot less now
because of video meetings.
I've found that the
way that you work now
versus the way you'd work
five years ago or 10 years ago
changes.
And that's really,
really effective.
More employee satisfaction,
more for retaining,
people analyzing data.
So you've got more
people analyzing data,
and the people that already
knew how to analyze data
can do it much, much faster
and can do a better job.
Less time creating documents.
We didn't even
talk about the fact
that the documents are better
because you're doing real time
co-editing on them.
So they're actually
higher quality,
and they're more reflective
of the team's output.
So huge benefits here on
the productivity side.
Cost reductions-- the
utilization factor
that is just inherent.
There's an inherent difference
in a centralized cloud model
and a siloed on-premise model.
There's really no way
to get around that.
That's one of the first
reasons that cloud caught on.
And it's obvious, you just
can't change the math.
Taking a bunch of spiky loads
and averaging them together
you get a flatter
load that allows
you to have better
utilization of resources.
Being able to specialize--
it's kind of strange
that we've ever
got to this model where it was
expected that every company had
to become an expert in
running a data center.
That seems like an
odd thing, right?
Like every company is an
expert in every other field,
why would they have
to be an expert
in running a data center?
It's a very
specific, niche task.
And there's not
really much reason
for a manufacturing
company to be an expert
in running a data center.
And so you can specialize
and your IT staff
can focus on solving
problems that
are relevant to your industry.
Security-- we talked about
the threat and the importance
of security is going
up all the time.
You can look at all
of the recent data
breaches that are in the news.
Everyone knows that's just
the tip of the iceberg.
It is happening more and more.
And this is an existential
threat to companies.
And so they've got to make
sure you're staying ahead
of these ever increasing
and ever more sophisticated
security threats.
And then, of course, agility--
the one thing, again, from
the keynote this morning
that really struck me was the
stat that Diane gave about how
the average age of companies
now is significantly
less than the average age
of companies 20 years ago,
40 years ago.
And you see that.
You see whole industries
being turned over
and the players changing.
And so you've got to be agile.
You've got to be able to
adapt to those changes.
Again, you can see
them as cost savings,
but they're also just
fundamental to being
successful in business.
And then the last piece, this is
a little more straightforward,
the math.
Just flat out replacement.
Replacing point
solutions with a suite.
It's more efficient.
It seems to be the way
that the industry is going,
and we're firm
believers in that.
We obviously support
all of these categories
inherent in the product, and we
partner with the best in class
people everywhere.
But for a lot of people,
an integrated package
is going to work really well.
And so with that I
wanted to wrap up and say
thanks, everyone, for coming.
[MUSIC PLAYING]